bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce matin la France est en demi-finale
contre le Maroc ça se passera mercredi
soir certains redoutent alors je vais
tout de suite un peu assombrir le
tableau mais certains redoutent des
affrontements est-ce qu'il y aura pas
aussi un une forme de match politique
c'est un énorme enfin on peut juste
prendre deux minutes pour célébrer on
est en demi-finale et parce qu'on est en
demi-finale alors oui on a le droit
d'être extrêmement heureux de regarder
ce match d'imaginer ce mal faire en
famille ou entre amis et de ne pas aller
chercher et bien tous ces discours un
peu de division personne n'a le droit de
gâcher cette fête et en même temps ça va
être un match assez magique en réalité
assez historique parce que c'est le
Maroc qui sera également demi-finale et
il se trouve que je connais très bien ce
pays j'y ai grandi pour une partie de ma
vie je l'aime beaucoup et pour autant
moi j'ai envie qu'on ramène cette
deuxième étoile cette troisième étoile
puisqu'on a ramené la deuxième donc
votre cœur de balance pas entre la
France et le Maroc moi j'ai envie qu'on
ramène cette troisième étoile parce que
dans le fond ça serait la première fois
on aurait deux étoiles consécutives ça
nous rentre dans l'histoire et pour
autant moi j'ai été extrêmement bluffé
par la qualité du jeu de l'équipe de
l'équipe marocaine par sa défense par
l'unité qui a dans dans son équipe dans
finalement cette solidarité aussi et
puis dans la joie dans la journée vous
ne redoutez pas des affrontements après
le match non franchement à chaque fois
que quelqu'un essaye d'assombrir et bien
cette célébration il y a encore il y a
très peu de choses qui nous permettent
de célébrer d'être heureux sont rares
ces moments le foot le permet donc on va
éviter ça et pour l'éviter évidemment
c'est d'abord un appel à la raison et
puis ne pas mélanger les choses c'est
d'abord un très beau match un très beau
match sportif c'est deux pays qui sont
amis qui vont jouer et moi j'ai envie de
garder en tout cas en tête cette
magnifique image aujourd'hui cette une
du Parisien où il y a deux drapeaux ces
deux pays qui ont fait un exploit
sportif que le meilleur gagne même si
évidemment nous avons envie d'aller
chercher cette troisième l'équipe de
France de foot c'est un modèle pour les
jeunes
écoutez en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est que le sport les sports en général
mais le football peut-être en tant que
sport collectif pose effectivement un
certain nombre de règles et de modèles
pas dans quand on entend les excès et
parfois les salaires
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que c'est aussi l'argent roi
est-ce que c'est ça le modèle non c'est
pas ça le modèle par contre le foot au
quotidien et moi je le vois chez moi à
Nantes ou à Grandchamps ce sont des
équipes ce sont des équipes qui
respectent des règles c'est énormément
de bénévoles qui encadrent les enfants
qui les emmènent faire un match le
samedi ou le dimanche c'est beaucoup de
solidarités intergénérationnelles c'est
des moments encore qu'on partage en
famille et ça va être ça mercredi ça va
être un moment où bah le cœur va
s'emballer parce que nous sommes un
peuple de foot dans le fond et le foot
c'est aussi le respect des règles et je
trouve que dans un moment comme celui
qu'on est en train de vivre aujourd'hui
dur où il y a beaucoup de fractures et
divisions et bien profiter de ces
moments d'unité ça fait bien vous avez
pas voulu inciter les jeunes à boycotter
les matchs ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que d'une certaine manière on
ignore les sujets comme les droits de
l'Homme ou les droits LGBT les morts sur
les chantiers on les met de côté on
ignore rien jamais c'est pas l'héritage
de la France la France a toujours été
extrêmement offensive oui mais ça
partait la ministre samedi dernier
portait à la mise des sports un pull au
manche arc-en-ciel mis à part ça on n'a
rien fait tout le président Emmanuel
Macron il se rallumait mercredi et c'est
normal que le Président de la République
soit aux côtés de notre équipe nationale
et aux côtés des Bleus pour aller
arracher avec ferveur cette coupe du
monde un peu plus
des droits de l'homme nous sommes
responsables de ce qu'on porte comme
idéal et comme défense de nos valeurs la
dignité humaine ne sera jamais foulée au
pied à nos côtés la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui demander aux jeunes ou
demander aux Français de boycotter un
moment populaire comme celui de la Coupe
du Monde c'est excusez-moi
idiot parce que dans le fond c'est aller
les culpabiliser alors que la décision a
été prise par des responsables en
réalité fallait pas marquer quand même
politiquement parce que les murs du
Qatar là pour lui tout va bien il a
réussi son Mondial les présidents de
monde entier sont venus vous savez dans
les tribus vous savez il y a pas de
encore une fois moi je crois qu'il faut
pas prendre un peu en otage cette Coupe
du Monde il y a un certain nombre de
points de bilan sur les questions
environnementales sur les questions de
dignité humaine la ministre des Sports
l'a fait le présent de la République va
soutenir notre notre équipe dont on est
fier notre équipe nationale mais moi je
mélange pas les questions diplomatiques
et ce moment extrêmement populaire du
foot et c'est pour ça que je dis très
simplement aux jeunes et au moins jeunes
écoutez continuons à célébrer ces sports
collectifs à côté de ça la
responsabilité d'État comme le nôtre
parce que nous avons cette charge et
bien c'est de continuer à faire évoluer
le droit de soutenir notre héritage
c'est-à-dire l'égalité entre les droits
donc
mercredi soir Emmanuel Macron face aussi
un geste il sera dans les tribunes il
sera dans le stade vous savez le
président de la République est souverain
et même si tout ne se voit pas l'enfant
le la mobilisation de la France pour les
questions de droits sont absolument
essentiels c'est le premier président de
la République à avoir nommé un
ambassadeur en charge des droits LGBT en
particulier parce que il y a d'abord un
seul et unique combat la dignité humaine
et l'égalité il y a beaucoup de
publicité pour les paris sportifs avant
et après les matchs alors je sais que
vous avez écrit à l'arcom c'est à dire
l'agence de régulation l'audiovisuelle
pour vous inquiéter des Vaisse sur le
sur les sur les jeunes qu'est-ce que
vous a répondu l'arcom c'est extrêmement
honteux de voir que aujourd'hui 35% de
nos jeunes entre 15 et 17 ans ont déjà
parié alors que c'était interdit c'est
interdit un tiers de nos adolescents
quand même et on sait à quel point cette
addictif à cet âge-là au-delà de ça on a
des publicités qui sont extrêmement
offensives qui cible les jeunes en
particulier même les des quartiers
populaires plus spécifiquement écoutez
l'arcom et la NJ ont en réalité des
outils juridiques pour condamner
financièrement et on sait que le nerf de
la guerre donc c'est ça va bouger durant
la pub mercredi nous sommes en pleine
discussion sur également la capacité à
faire de la prévention à dire par
exemple le risque de perte et donc du
coup d'avoir une décision éclairée mais
ce qui est ce qui n'est pas entendable
ce qui n'est pas acceptable c'est de
profiter de cet élan de ce grand moment
populaire pour aller cibler des jeunes
en particulier et prendre le risque de
l'addiction le Conseil national la
refondation se retrouve aujourd'hui
c'est une séance un peu un peu bilan
d'étape ça fait 7 mois que c'est
conférences ont lieu un peu partout en
France à Paris mais aussi en région à ce
stade on voit que deux décisions la
gratuité pour les jeunes
ce qui concerne les préservatifs et puis
la possibilité pour les médecins à la
retraite d'enchaîner avec une activité
tout en touchant leur retraite c'est
vrai que pour l'instant c'est un petit
peu léger comme un bilan d'étape vous y
voyez un bilan très restrictif moi je
vois c'est plusieurs centaines en
réalité de réunions thématiques de
cnr-thématiques qui se trouve que avec
papendaye moi je regarde en particulier
les CNR éducation dans nos territoires
comment s'aboutira sur quoi aujourd'hui
il y aura le bilan d'étapes porté par le
Président de la République par la
première ministre et avec un certain
nombre du de ministres qui seront
présents j'en serai aujourd'hui les
conclusions seront faites en fin de
journée mais surtout ce n'est pas la fin
puisque on a fait samedi un CNR jeunesse
qui aura vocation à rayonner sur le
territoire parce que c'est des bails se
font au plus près des jeunes on va donc
être patient merci beaucoup Sarah